okay well let's play the ready opening
which can clearly transpose into a lot
let's do this transposing into the
caro-kann and now this what do we call
this what's the name of this I really
don't know and the it it doesn't it
doesn't really show up the
transpositions like it won't label it on
CH s cube when you arrive at a
particular position fit ah is a
different move order and such but uh
what is this line cod I know we're in
the caro-kann but bring the two nights
variation or something maybe of the
caro-kann I'm familiar okay this is like
the main line caro-kann but i don't have
this deform move in just yet and i'm
pretty sure that after h 497 is needed
now this i think is an issue so i'll let
you think of it for a little bit those
that are tuned in now how would you
respond to a move such as this age six
what do you do what's the plan what's
the big deal what's the scoop what's the
story any of the above that I just
referenced what do you do what would you
do now that I've given you a few seconds
to think about it I just got I gotta
keep moving forward 95 and i believe the
97 move was needed so that I can't play
here with tempo on the bishop if I
played h5 here that's just getting
caught up in a rout in the routine
because it's something that's played in
the main line and maybe h5 there is not
take you know not showing as a
wrong and understanding is this
particular with this particular
variation because along the way you know
each for its preparing this 95 move with
tempo and then that 97 mode i think is
needed so as a follow-up i think this is
correct in here i have to be a little
concerned about this guy so this mate
threat sometimes that this pond will
sometimes have already played to e6 and
there could be like lateral defense with
queen here as awkward as it is or queen
c7 but now it's turning out that g6 is
needed and then the Queen could she
could come back to this square and still
threatened me and then the night could
block and then the Queen can actually
come over here and threaten mate again
and b7 I think this might be a winning
continuation can you believe that my
queen is going to start dancing she's
gonna start her little dance she's gonna
do a little shuffle to h5 come back to
f3 hit f7 go over to be three hit f7
again along with b7 and that's I think
TKO and I have to be a bit cautious
though because maybe I could be dropping
my knight in certain lines like Knight
f6 perhaps you excuse me g6 and queen
here Knight f6 queen bee three Queen D
five stops the main thread on f7 hits my
night but I can take here allow Queen
takes Knight with check and there's no
stopping Queen takes rook later if the
Queen does take my night in that
variation do i block with my bishop yeah
I think that that is quite alright my
night is always there to watch over it
as well if if there was a bishop takes
and then some pressure on this pond so
let's let's play here is there anything
better I doubt it matin one threat the
night blocks
another matin one threat unless this
move is played and then the kingside is
seriously compromised these issues that
black is now presented with is happening
just because of the h6 move instead of a
knight a timely night d7 move oh I
didn't see that Queen d5 move here ah
Queen d5 could be played here okay well
it's time to shift gears and recognize
that that little variation I thought
would be good is no longer good because
Queen d5 can be played a move earlier so
this is a good defense in probably the
best defense very nice so what do you do
when your opponent defends like that you
take the Queen and you still actually
have something good up your sleeve
because now there's tricks on f7 or
tricks on the rookie is actually when
still so the Queen d5 actually turns out
to not be well that's that's still just
not good one so i guess Knight f6 was
maybe still best somehow i don't know i
ate it's it's getting everything is my
attention is drawn back to move six move
11 here but it's move number six where
there was a slip and now pieces fall
all right is there anything better than
taking the rook well actually well now
let's just take it and then run away
before it's defended my night could be
captured so just want to develop here
there's not much else to do i'm up that
rook and the main point i think i could
already summarize it during this game
right here it's just going to be that
age six move we'll have a closer look as
to as to well this this actually is an
example of why not to do it or so we're
seeing a very significant electric
oliveri a very good reason why not to go
with age six there and how it is of
great importance to meet a Knight f3
move with watching over the e5 square
okay this is a not that really the best
spot to throw a bishop but I did that so
i could just rescue my night grab
another pond and let's get this pawn up
follow up with c3 a little not little
box out this night bishop here soon
actually let me do this I'm flushing
that Bishop backwards okay they get a
piece back Brooke ga
um
okay this is trouble look here i have
just h5 and what else my opponent is
typing my way here my opponent is saying
that they messed things up at well let
me tell you that it's very easy to just
slip up it's a it doesn't seem it seems
innocent enough to go with age six
instead of 97 but yeah it's it could
really turn into something really really
messy so there's they're really i don't
know that there was a good thing that
you could have been doing maybe mmm I
don't know it's really tough let me look
back here let's see if there was
something more I think it does turn out
to be dead as long as white is able to
follow up correctly h4 what do you do
nitin or wait a second no no no no no no
no no what am I saying I just kept
saying 1997 huh i trap i trapped a
bishop what am I talking about 97 I'm
you see it one thing that I'm messed up
with is what I messed up with the the
mainline kara where there's that this
pot is already on d4 hmm
what's the move here whoa whoa I better
be able to make sense over this let's
see Bishop out night here boom h4 if 97
I just play age 5 and he's cooked so and
even if h5 is played it doesn't matter
like this night is just going to be a
beast anyhow there's gonna be a beast
wow so many give me some insight here
look it up click or something what's the
scoop is does white already stand better
at this point right here might it be
this move that needs some work Bishop
this to this square maybe it's better to
just pin the night and not run for this
on main line
bishop
huh I'm a bit confused here bit confused
let's see because this is a problem h6
night here clean out these are all
really forcing moves you gotta block I'm
threatening f7 I have this swinging over
to be three available and this is this
has already lights out somebody's coming
up with the line here okay okay I'm
getting out some insight here let me go
back thank you for the insight let's
flip here let me see something I want to
have some closure to this so move number
four if Bishop g4 h3 Bishop takes Queen
takes and then you just fix your pawns
on light squares that's one approach and
another is oh yeah another is this
Knight f6 move I think what we're seeing
is that food I think what we're seeing
is that Bishop f5 is not a good move
here because after the night retreats
coming back to g6 runs into some trouble
um there you have it you have is that
the verdict can I just be could I be
that certain of it can i really be that
certain that Bishop f5 is not a good
idea because it seems pretty forceful
the moves thereafter what are your other
decisions with your bishop do you come
here you could have come there in one
shot maybe here is the best move at this
point but I don't know about even coming
out well okay I guess your
decentralizing my night before you play
here so maybe it's okay Bishop g4 in
this position and then after h3 chop
chop okay I think this is a better one
right here Bishop to g4 right now if you
come back here in serious hot water
beware you're in some serious hot water
you are definitely in some sea
his hot water then okay yeah oh you know
what because this other here's the
here's the thing the night is usually
not on see knight on f3 at this point
excuse me not on f3 at this point but
rather d4 is played in place of Knight
to f3 but being that it's already here
h4 age 6 the night could come here in
one shot got it I'm seeing the
difference between the move order now
I'm seeing the differences here I'm
learning I'm learning things right now
on stream here learning the difference
between them having the knight on f3
opposed to having that d form of which
is a straight mainline caricom dd4 c6
receive me for c6 d4 d5 Knight c3 night
pawn takes pawn Knight takes pawn Bishop
f5 night g3 Bishop back and again this
night has just not moved up so if this
is the position you got to go to g4
right now g6 you're going to get a
beating and that was that's that's what
turned out to be the main problem easy
very very easy to do very very easy to
get caught up in the routine main line I
honestly did not think that this was a
bad idea during the game and it's only
after looking at the game right now that
you know I am seeing it as an issue
because he I was saying during the game
you had to play night d7 right now what
was I was I thinking I'm doing this with
the serious threat and you met that but
there's there's trouble elsewhere ok
anyhow i think i have spoken enough on
that one interesting thing to take away
from the opening phase of the caro-kann
cool